So we're tracking a whole bunch of vaccine
trials and development for Corona virus vaccines.
And there's news from a couple of different
vaccine manufacturers or researchers that
I think is relevant, important and potentially
optimistic, which think we could use a little
bit of right now.
So the first one is Oxford University.
Oxford University could have a vaccine ready
to be used in September.
The reason that Oxford has a head start is
that they've already been working on a vaccine
for prior corona viruses and they already
have proven of the formula, so to speak, to
be harmless to humans.
From a safety perspective.
So Oxford already has a vaccine for this specific
corona virus.
Last month in a lab in Montana, they tested
this specific vaccine on rhesus monkeys.
They give the monkeys the vaccine.
They expose the monkeys to huge amounts of
the virus.
The monkeys without the vaccine all got the
virus.
And more than 28 days later, the six monkeys
that had been vaccinated did not get the virus
at any point in time.
That's huge.
The rhesus monkey is the closest thing to
Homo sapiens for the purposes of testing vaccines.
You can read a lot about that.
If that's interesting to you.
Now, is it guaranteed that a vaccine that
is safe in humans and works in rhesus monkeys
will work just as well to create immunity
in humans?
No, it's not a guarantee, but it's a very
good sign.
Next step is human trials of this specific
vaccine.
They're going to be doing a trial with 6000
people by the end of May.
That's very, very big and will be really important
to see how that goes.
Now, the question is, does it work to prevent
Corona virus in humans?
That's what this six thousand person test
is meant to figure out.
And a few important things here to think about.
Number one.
OK, how does a vaccine work?
The vaccine contains an element of the germ
that makes people sick.
It could be a killed or weakened version of
the germ so that the vaccine doesn't give
you the disease.
That would be a disaster.
Some vaccines have just part of the germ.
It's enough of the germ.
The idea is whether it's been weakened or
it's only a part of it or it's dead germ.
It's got to be enough that the body reacts
by making antibodies, which then in an ideal
world makes you immune to the full germ if
you were to be invaded by it.
And you have to go through numerous steps,
including testing the vaccines for safety,
testing the vaccine for efficacy, seeing if
it generates what is the right dose to generate
enough antibodies that you will be immune.
You can have a situation where the vaccine
is safe in the sense that it doesn't harm
humans, but it might not make you immune.
There can be cases where the vaccine could
make you have a more serious version of the
disease.
If you were to be infected, that would be
a disaster, of course.
So what needs to happen for this vaccine to
be useable in September?
First, you've got to test the six thousand
humans in May.
That has to go well.
Number two, there often is a production issue
when it comes to vaccines, because if you
wait until you know it's the vaccine to use
to start production, you're behind and you've
lost a really important time that could be
used to start vaccinating people.
So what they're going to do is now or soon
they will start production of this vaccine
before they even know for sure that it's going
to be the vaccine.
This is to be able to have at least some millions
of doses ready as soon as it's determined
that this is a vaccine that works.
And then lastly, important, if it were to
be available in September, it's not going
to be everybody.
And their mother goes and gets this vaccine
in September.
If everything goes perfectly in September,
there would be a few million doses.
It would probably be authorized under emergency
use.
And probably at that stage it would just be
for health care, health care workers, which
makes sense and then subsequently for the
most vulnerable people in populations.
So this is all good news, but most likely
there will be more than one vaccine that's
used when things get going because of the
number of doses globaly that are going to
be needed.
So a couple of questions that now come up.
Will this be like a flu vaccine that's only
effective against like that year's strain
or mutation answer?
We don't know.
There's a research paper that says that the
vaccine candidates for this.
Corona virus would match all circulating strains
of the virus, but not that they would work
on all corona viruses.
That's an important distinction there would
be of the vaccines being worked on now.
We already have at least my moderately different
strains of this Corona virus that have spread
due to mutation.
The vaccine would likely work on all of those,
but it would not work on any corona virus.
As you know, there are many corona viruses,
including common colds can sometimes be caused
by corona viruses.
The good news is that Cauvin, 19, seems more
stable than the flu virus.
The mutation rate is much lower.
That helps hopefully have one that will work
longer than the flu vaccine works.
It's all speculation.
We just don't know at this point.
One other bit of hopeful vaccine news.
So this is the Oxford trial I've been telling
you about.
The there's a German company working with
Pfizer, which has also started human trials,
and they could potentially have millions of
vaccines ready in the 2020 calendar year.
Now, that could be November.
It could be the end of December, but they're
starting tests in the US next week.
The idea is emergency use on the table in
the fall.
And if they get moving on production soon
before they even know for sure that it'll
work, could have a few million doses available.
They say that twelve participants have been
vaccinated since the start of the study on
April 23rd.
No results yet.
Many things happening.
One thing I'm going to address at the end
of the show in the voice mail segment is whether
I would want to be at the front of the line
for these vaccines.
I'll address that in
a
little bit.